and I really love Joe Goldberg this
season it really reminded me of Dan
Humphrey in Gossip Girl you know this
fish out of water in London's Elite
Society did you feel any similarities
uh no next question I'm kidding
um oh crap I'm not the first person to
ask this
uh look Joe has always been in the realm
of Dan Humphrey a bit there's a there's
like a there's like a cultural
conversation between them
there's always been this joke that in a
lot of ways Joe Goldberg is picking up
where Dan Humphrey left off and just
grabbing a knife and and killing people
I mean first season of the first episode
of season one feels very much like Dan
Humphrey then from there it sort of turn
on its head so and then yeah and so in
the long maybe Boomerang away from that
vibe there is a return to the rubbing
shoulders with the elite but Joe has
always done that he's just doing it a
bit more and then and it's in England so
I think in some ways
it feels
Wes like Gossip Girl than it had been
previously so but I don't know I mean
to me to me all television is somewhere
in the realm of Gossip Girl you know I
totally agree
yeah it makes sense uh Amy now that
you've been a part of the world of you
Joe Goldberg continues to be this
character that the internet can't stop
they're staying over do you understand
the appeal to this character still after
all the things that he's done
I I do because I watched show before and
you
absolutely loved it I did I said I did
I'm not just saying that I did love it
um but you do like like that Joe has
this quality about him where you I don't
know why you root for him I mean I mean
it's it's a credit department as an
actor but you do want the best for him
and I don't know why and I think that's
kind of adds to the mystery of the show
is that you don't know why you wrote for
this guy but you do and you actually do
what the best for him I don't know maybe
I think it's because I mean look we
designed him to be that way he's meant
to be
very Charming you know to me I think
he's actually
he's impossibly Charming I don't know
that somebody who's
genuinely capable of all this murder and
all this way and not just murder like
the boxing of people mostly women you
know it's the stalking it's a very it's
a it's a is he really capable of you
know the loving longing moments that
he's known for is he really capable of
loving someone like Paco someone like
Ellie and then Nadia like I I don't I
don't know so in that way to me it's
more of like this Camp High Drama
Fantasy exploration what
he's not a real person you know that's
my I think I think we we
've made him that way and we keep making
him that way for a reason
well you're not helping people with the
beard and the Tweed suits people are
loving that even more now
it'll be polarizing I bet you there'll
be camps I don't know
um then you obviously shot this season
in London I know your wife Domino is
from the UK what does she think of Joe
Goldberg's British Invasion
I mean she really loved visiting being
out yeah
yeah they weren't able to come as much
as we would have liked but um but uh
yeah she loved being home in fact
absolutely
almost like a different tone to it I
love the whole you know Joe has a
stalker the murder mystery Amy what are
you excited for the Die Hard fans to see
when it comes to the season not just
excited what are they going to be
surprised about with this season
I think they're gonna be surprised
because you're you're used to Joe having
all of the Power you know yeah the one
in control and and he's everything that
happens is happening because of his
actions as well now the power's
completely been taken out of his hands
and it's all about him navigating what's
going on around him
um and I think that's what's you know
really great about bringing it to
England and what's great about the
season as well but you still have you
still have the essence of like Joe so
it's yeah it's brilliant I think that's
the first half that is because the two
it's part one and part two and then yeah
it's different so but that's part one
that I'm talking about more so yeah
yeah that's what I love so much about
the season too they both so which was
really fun um congrats you guys I can't
wait for him to see you thank you so
much thank you